معكم
او
هذه مساله مهمه
هو
تايم
صلى اللهك
المنافقون قالوا نشهد انك لرسول
‏when
come
they
remember with behavi they
be
والله انكسوله
سبحانه وتالى
الله
والله يشهد ان المنافق قين لكاذبون طيب
الكلمه حق ايوه الكلمه حق لكن القلب غير
مصدق اذا اذا كان القلب غير مصدق
فالكلمه
باعتبار القائل كذب في حقه وان كانت
الكلمه صدق في ذاتها
true
‏troc
[Silence]
you are
‏Allah responds and says and Allah knows
that you are his messenger.
And Allah testifies
that the hypocrites are liars.
The statement itself is true. Yes, but
they didn't believe it. And so even if a
person says something that is true but
they do not believe it, it is considered
to be a for them.
‏So when we understand this now we
understand that
is not just truthfulness
it's truness and truthfulness truness in
the heart truthfulness
with with what we say and we said that
in order for something
in the law of Allah to beed truth
‏number
[Silence]
‏with respect to the person not the
statement itself
this is so important and so overled by
people
you look
our
society today our larger society today
is a society that is largely not
completely not entirely but largely
and we speaking
আল্লাহ
this super super sweet sweetness you
know smiles andake
if we were to look at the companions of
the
صلى الله عليه وسلم
interacting with each other
based on our norms today our societal
norms we might consider them to dislike
each other these guys don't really like
each other that much why
because when they met each other they
would smile
[Silence]
‏somees a
right
bond was unbreakable
they have a
‏eat
please eat
you go through this process here right
as the h to beat you over the head with
as you're expect to
re as much as possible until we finally
relent to the fact that we know you're
going to eat and i know that right
companions never did this
‏propet صلى الله عليه وسلم was drinking
some milk and
was there was prepared for marage and
other around her propank
and said drink said no okay said do not
be hungry
لا تجمع بين الكذب والجوع
السلام
‏would
into backive
ag this passive agiveness this was
key marks of hypocry when they would see
someone behaving this
[Silence]
‏ion
الله عنهم
عائشه رضي الله عنها رات متسكه
‏of youer generation
they almost monkish in their behavi
they were very you know
and kind of this kind of fake humility
right kind of walking very soft and like
a little pigon walking right because the
was
عائشه رضي الله عنها
هؤلاء متن
رحم الله عمر نعمك
كان
كان اذا قال اسمع واذا مشى اسرع واذا ضرب
اوجع واذا اطعم اشبع
عمر
people
strength thatake humility didn't have
that was here but
‏walked he was fast and firm in his in
his walk and his stride was powerful and
when he spoke he made himself heard and
when he hit someone he made it hurt and
when he fed someone he made them full
that's humility
not this
a little bird will come and eat my
breakfast if you know just I'm too soft
I'm too humble the humility is just too
الله
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يعلمنا التقوى وان يطهر اعمالنا وان
يصلح
اي وان يؤمن روعاتنا وان يستر عورات نا
نساله تعالى ان يطهر قلوبنا وان يغزل يغسل
حباتنا ونساله تعالى ان يسلل سخيمه قلوبنا
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا